purchases are intended to run until the
end of September 2016 and in any case
until we see a sustained adjustment in
the path of inflation that is consistent
with our aim of achieving inflation
rates below but close to 2% over the
medium-term there is clear evidence that
the monetary policy measures we put in
place are effective financial market
conditions and the cost of external
finance for the private sector have
eased considerably over the past months
and borrowing conditions for firms and
households have improved notably with a
pickup in the demand for credits while
remaining on the dies on the downside
the risks surrounding the economic
outlook for the euro area have become
more balanced on account of the recent
monetary policy decisions the fall in
oil prices and the lower euro exchange
rate we approve the LA and will continue
to do so
extend extending liquidity to the Greek
banks while they are solvent and they
have adequate collateral so far we
reached an exposure to Greece of 110
billion euros which is the highest in
the euro area here relation to GDP